-Our next guest has been
continuing the work
of her parents,
Dr. Martin Luther King Jr.
and Coretta Scott King,
as the CEO of The King Center.
She also co-wrote a new
children's book,
called "It Starts with Me!,"
which is available now
at thekingcenter.org.
[ Drumroll ]
Please welcome
Dr. Bernice A. King.
♪♪
-Oh, it's nice to see you again!
[ Laughs ]
Thank you so much.
-Yeah, it's good to see you
as well.
-It's nice to see you.
Next time,
we must do it in person, please.
-Yes, definitely.
-We just celebrated
Martin Luther King Jr. Day
a few weeks ago.
And I follow you
on all the socials
and you're a good follow.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you so much.
-I love your messaging,
but I love also,
you said, on that day, you said,
"Please also remember
my mother on this day,"
because your mother
had a lot to do
with why we celebrate
Martin Luther King Jr. Day.
-Well, I always say to people,
you know,
when my father was assassinated,
he was one of the most hated
persons in America
and now he's one of the most
loved persons in the world.
And some people would argue,
"Well, that's because
he's no longer with us
to challenge people,"
and things of that nature.
But I would argue that
that may be part of the reason,
but it's also because
Coretta Scott King
dedicated her life
after their life in the movement
to institutionalize his legacy
in this country
by creating and founding
The Martin Luther King Jr.
Center for Nonviolent
Social Change,
which I serve as the CEO of,
and working for the holiday.
And so, many of the ways that we
remember, recall Dr. King today
is because she
was very strategic
in the way in which she ensured
that we would remember him,
recognize him, and have
his teachings available.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Exactly right.
You've continued your parents'
legacy with The King Center
and you have a program called
Nonviolence365,
which is now online.
Can you explain what that is,
Nonviolence365?
-Yeah, actually, it's
an immersive online experience,
about 16 hours,
where people will learn
about the foundation
of nonviolence
that my father developed
and was influenced by many
theologians and philosophers
and his upbringing,
how he used those
in his campaigns
throughout the movement.
And they will learn
about the principles
and steps of nonviolence
and then how to apply them
in real-life
circumstances today.
So, there are exercises,
there are quizzes,
there are scenarios.
There are extensive interviews
with practitioners,
those people who are instructors
of nonviolence,
veterans of the movement.
By the time somebody goes
through this experience,
they would have learned
this nonviolent philosophy
and methodology
and how to use it to deal with,
not just conflict,
but how to engage and dismantle
injustice and inequities
and how to take it forth
practically into your home,
your workplace,
in your communities,
and even in your schools.
-Yeah.
I have a photo here, again.
This is from Instagram.
-[ Laughs ]
-It's from Instagram.
I love this.
It says,
"Just a father taking care
of his little girl."
[ Audience awws ]
That's you.
-I was up to something,
as you can see.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you're doing
something, yeah.
-Yes. I was waiting
for him to finish.
[ Laughter ]
-You were figuring
something out.
But I was going to ask you,
how old are you,
you think, around here
-Probably about three
and a half to four.
And, believe it or not --
and I didn't know this --
when you zoom in --
You probably can see it there.
But when you zoom in,
that's Mahalia Jackson
in the background.
-Oh, my gosh!
-I never knew that
in all these years.
I just discovered
that the other day
when I re-looked at the photo.
Apparently,
she was at Ebenezer Church
for something and, yeah,
that's pretty cool.
-When you were this young,
when you were a kid,
were you aware
of what your parents did?
-I had not a clue.
He was Daddy, she was Mommy,
and we had a special game
that we used to play.
It was my game.
There were certain things he did
with all of the siblings,
like putting us up
on the refrigerator
and we'd jump off into his arms.
-[ Laughs ]
-But I had this kissing game
where, when he would come home
off the road,
there was a certain spot
on the face
that I would kiss him,
related to each one of us.
So mine was on the forehead,
my two brothers were
on either cheek,
my sister was off to the corner
of the mouth,
my mother was smack-dab
in the middle.
[ Laughter ]
-He would take me up
in his arms, say,
"Hey!
Let's play the kissing game.
Now, where is Yoki's" --
which is my sister's nickname --
"...sugar spot?"
So he called them sugar spots.
I don't know what that meant
in the Black community.
I don't know what that meant,
but that's what we called them,
sugar spots.
[ Laughter ]
It wasn't sweet.
I can tell you that.
[ Laughter ]
It was a sweet gesture.
Maybe that's what it was.
-So cute.
I love the book, by the way.
You know,
I love children's books
and it's called
"It Starts with Me!"
and all the profits go
to The King Center.
Can you talk
about the book's message
and also the Beloved Community?
-Yeah. So we wrote this book
on the heels of a campaign
we were doing called BE LOVE.
With all of the polarization
and the divisiveness
and the vitriol in our nation,
we wanted to inject love
as the power to change
and transform our society
because my father said that,
"Power at its best
is love Implementing
the demands of justice
and justice at its best
is love correcting everything
that stands against love."
So, as we were going
through this whole process
and getting people to join us
and taking a pledge --
and they can go there even now
and take that pledge
as adults --
we wanted to bring in children,
so we decided to do
this children's book.
And the little character's name
is Amora
because, you know, in French,
"amour" means "love."
And so Amora is encouraging
her friends to BE LOVE,
to open up their hearts
and open up their minds
to let love guide their words --
especially with kids --
their actions,
and their thoughts.
And to be a part of creating
the Beloved Community
and teaching them that love
is very powerful,
transformative, that it's kind,
that it fights against hate,
that it stands up for justice,
and so many other things.
And so the Beloved Community is
really about creating a society
that's based
in justice and equity
and where people are treated
with respect and dignity
and where conflicts are resolved
in a peaceful manner.
Because there is conflict
in the Beloved Community,
but you're committed
to the dignity of every person
and working it out
and you you're also committed
to ensuring
that there's justice
and equity for everyone.
And so we wanted children
as part of that journey
and that's why
we wrote this book.
-I love it.
Please don't stop.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Please don't stop!
You are awesome.
Please don't stop.
-Thank you.
-Dr. Bernice A. King.
For more information
on "It Starts with Me!"
and Nonviolence365,
go to thekingcenter.org.